les très attendus premières doses seront
administrés à partir de ce mercredi à
environ quarante mille professionnels de
la santé volontaires médecins et
infirmières de 100 hôpitaux du japon
sont concernés le gouvernement a été
très prudents et nous avons donc décidé
de faire les essais cliniques avec des
japonais pour montrer que nous avons
tout fait pour prouver l'innocuité et
l'efficacité du vaccin réservé dans un
premier temps un nombre réduit de
personnels hospitaliers la vaccination
sera ensuite élargie aux autres
professionnels de santé
elle ne sera pas étendue aux personnes
âgées avant avril au plus tôt le reste
de la population devant attendre
plusieurs semaines voire plusieurs mois
al'approche des jo de tokyo je ne prends
pas vraiment en considération les jeux
olympiques
mon travail est de déployer le vaccin au
fur et à mesure que les sommes
approvisionnés par l'europe
un feu vert réglementaire a été accordée
au vaccin de pfizer biotech
le japon a également conclu des accords
avec les laboratoires astrazeneca et
moderna afin d'obtenir suffisamment de
doses pour ses 126 millions d'habitants